all right Carrie is with us in Houston
Texas hi Carrie welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi Dave how are you better
than I deserve how are you I'm
definitely better than I deserve
however I'm trying to settle a debt a
credit card debt and I've given them an
offer you know told them this is all I
have figure leave it and they declined
it they came back it was $6,500 and they
came back and said the lowest will take
is 10,000 and the balance is what it
started off around 24 to 25,000 now it's
up to 29 with all the interest and fees
mm-hmm and how long has it been have
been since you've really about a year
okay oh yeah yeah and so you're offering
them about 20 cents on the dollar and
they're coming back and saying about 35
cents on the dollar is all they'll do
okay well you don't have $10,000 right I
well I saved I have nine thousand I was
trying to kind of lowball them you know
just to see if I listened to you all the
time
oh and okay when did I decline your
offer this is just this week okay well
let them sit a month okay when will they
sue that's what I'm worried about it's
been a year now there's not there's not
a magic yes there's not a magic lawsuit
date likely they will eventually sue on
one this big little ones a lot of times
they never do no $3,000 I may never see
you but on these 35 on these 30,000
dollar ones they may come around to it
because you can offer to settle if they
sue you
even then right you can settle the
lawsuit no you can go back to them again
and you know let it let them sit for or
five weeks they'll call you up again
don't worry
yeah they call every day well I'm not
gonna talk to him every day hang up on
them oh I don't maybe once a month all
into the phone now how would I would I
would answer the phone systematically
every two weeks and tell them you'll
talk to them every two weeks and then
every time you pick up the phone to say
are you calling to accept our offer
because I have $6,500 on the table and
when you are willing to accept that and
give that to me in writing that you're
accepting that then we
of a deal and if they come back and say
7,500 take it and close the deal okay
but get it in writing or don't give them
any money right and no electronic access
to your checking account you know that
yes because they will clean you any
higher than 7,500 oh I just made that up
but I mean at some point you're going to
settle this thing it may be that you
save up a little more money and you use
nine to settle it but nine on thirty is
not a bad deal all right
but you've offered them that and if you
want to just mess with them a little bit
it's just a negotiation and sometimes
you just have to stiff arm people and
let them lay in the mud a little bit
before they think about it okay good
yeah as long as you're not in a hurry
for any particular reason
no I just want it done and over with but
that's that's that's just your emotions
if those if those emotions start ruling
the day you're going to pay 20 to settle
this yeah because if they ever smell
that you're kind of wanting this done
then though they got you then so just
say listen I don't care if we ever
settle it well we're going to sue you
good I'll work with the attorney have at
it you know and I'm not going to talk to
you people every day I'll talk to you
once every two weeks or if you want to
leave a voicemail that you're willing to
accept our offer I'll call you back but
otherwise I'm just going to freaking
ignore you you get nothing until we have
a deal and have it in writing and there
will be no electronic access to my
checking account just go ahead and tell
them all of that I'll talk to you once
every two weeks to remind you what the
deal is
other than that I'm going to hang up on
you unless you've left a voicemail that
says you're willing to take the deal
okay great thanks so much Dave and
listen let me you want to really drive
them crazy you use the tongue use the
tone and volume that you're using with
me ah real thing real calm real
nonchalant real I don't give a crap tone
you with me it's just like well you guys
want to do you know what do you want to
do it's up to you look I'll talk to you
once every two weeks but I'm not going
to be abused by you I'm not playing your
games and I got $6,500 laying on the
table when you want to take that call me
back now listen for the dial tone and
hang
just real calm nothing that indicates in
your voice that you've gotten excited in
any way okay or angry or fearful in any
way they're listening for any any you
want to be monotone and have no emotion
be a psychopath about it okay I will try
my heart is alright if you can do that
you'll drive them crazy because they're
making notations of all the details of
the conversation and you're around your
name in your file into the computer
every time they call and then the
computer you know the supervisors and
the algorithms are watching those
notations and they're going to see
you're not you're they're not they're
not gonna play with you because that you
know they only mess with people they can
get away with it and so that's what
you're doing it's just a game with these
collectors they're a pain in the butt to
work with I'll tell you that hey thanks
for the call and a merry Christmas to
you hope you get it settled and get it
out of your life soon